nos dicen que juan correa a una tasa
constante recorre 17 kilómetros en dos
horas nos piden escribir una ecuación
que muestre la relación entre la
distancia recorrida de en kilómetros y
el tiempo que tardó en recorrer la h en
horas
ausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta
hay varias formas en las que podemos
resolver esto una es decir que el corre
a una tasa constante por lo que la
distancia es igual a una constante que
llamamos k multiplicada por el tiempo
que tardó en correr que es h sin duda
podemos encontrar el valor de k usando
la información que nos dan aquí aquí nos
dicen que cuando juan recorre 17
kilómetros se tarda dos horas en hacerlo
lo anotamos 17 kilómetros es igual acá
por 2 horas a que es igual que ausa en
el vídeo y traten de calcularlo si es
que no lo calcularon la primera vez que
les pedí que pasara en el vídeo hay
varias formas de despejar k para mí la
más sencilla es simplemente decir que
vamos a dividir ambos
de la ecuación entre dos horas y si lo
hacemos nos queda que k es igual a 17
entre 2 kilómetros por hora si dividimos
17 entre 2 nos da 8.5 así que acá es
igual a 8.5 kilómetros por hora si vemos
el enunciado nos piden escribir una
ecuación que muestre la relación entre d
y h así que podemos escribirla como de
igual a la constante de proporcionalidad
recordamos que es igual a 8.5 por h con
esto ya podemos responder a lo que nos
piden en el enunciado si quisiéramos
incluir las unidades diríamos que b es
igual a 8.5 kilómetros por hora por h
que está en horas con esto terminamos y
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo